hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to a brand new let's play of
Kerry dark secrets alright this is one
that has been recommended many many many
times over so uh navigating in that
music is loud one but it's damn ominous
gotta crank this down cuz it is a whole
new conversion mod and it's said in the
intro to suggest to play it you know one
gamma or else you won't get the full
thing of it but for you guys I have to
play it at one point two five so if
that's what if you see I'm not as scared
that's why it's what a body or a cat
what's that okay anyway this is a full
conversion mod so everything in this mod
is like in its own instance of amnesia
wake up we will wake up okay see where
you got Gary dark secrets time to wake
up
Keith
I know I'm ready for you
I don't know once again I don't know how
long this is gonna be but compared to
the other total conversion mod should
expect some pretty good length on it
either way should be good long loading
screen nothing to read here if you're
just seeing black I don't know but here
we go
[Music]
all right teams
Ceyda presents seda seda Gary dark
secrets ooh a TV oh that's enough TV for
me I should go and meet up with Nick so
we don't miss this part it's been
talking so much about uh-huh although I
have my suspicions this porous go to
blow to blow hard at an old mansion
sounds more creepy than fun uh-huh
it's probably going to be dark too and
Nick knows I hate that they hate the
dirty some batteries just in case
good thinking they should be my desk
they should be the up your nose all
right ah what a slob this guy is on the
mouse sensitivity is way way way too low
okay well I just get some hang out I'll
crank it up a bit and double it I do add
my better oh it's like running through
molasses sweet sassy my lassie anyway ah
that looks like a torch as you British
folks would say all right I should get
going now either way I wonder if it's
off oddly it's interesting a lot of
these mods are made in like Nordic
countries that's what I think the accent
is okay where do I go here that's locked
my own apartment is locked here behind
the painting nope
okay humping Oh No dar mine is it
hurting not humping okay
look good to me was this hello
this is new definitely
well now interesting I like I like new
things they are using tinderboxes not a
lighter seems to be set in modern times
so it's such a [ __ ] [ __ ] sure are you
talking to don't worry what are you
talking to me Sookie you see this isn't
so bad
hmm you're right it's actually kind of
cozy who are you talking to
I think this way well I'm good to not go
that way
four hours later four hours later
[Music]
yeah whoever else I'm talking to try
what it's my own I don't think so yeah
[Music]
the whole room was empty man shut up
don't call me names so
whoa
that doesn't sound good I know some good
sounds in that that didn't sound like
one of them or any of them
okay then I'm guessing it was an amnesia
poultice or was it a sleeping thing I
have no idea but I'm guessing this is
all in his head a lot last night
Oh but the rumbling is heard it sounded
to read for dream that rumbling I better
check what's going on I like the voice
actor definitely good I'm hoping for
good pre I've heard a lot of good things
about this money's like unbelievably
highly reviewed hey it's my flashlight
what why didn't I have that with me lose
all no more tinderboxes oh look it's
battery hmm interesting
hello hello okay
click-click it's dark legally
hello bunny and goodbye bunny alright
bring it on no oyster blood everywhere
you could guess like oh what the hell
happened here that's just no good that
person
shut up haunted piano two points chair
you did do something about this chair go
clean that up
get me out of here okay
so there seems to have been a murder
hmm but what was the murder weapon
whoa oh suspicious can't even tell how
many people died oh this looks perfectly
normal I think all just meanders through
the house a bit then I'll make my way
outside this door was an accomplice
it's god damn it what the hell was that
those words those words that they said
right there hey nothing yeah you're sure
we click I think this is like hello I
think this is like the flashlight from
penumbra oh I'm not doing so well my
sanity seems to be slipping
maybe I'm the murderer probably
how's new that was a new sound chair
kapow hello is anybody home I think I'll
walk towards the suspicious noise yeah
everything screams perfectly normal
looks like a caveman leaning over
nevermind
quickly ah no yes archives I should
realize whenever I pick up a key
something's gonna happen huh these
spacious looking feet ah what's going on
here what did you see
huh give me answers I jump on you okay I
guess you're not talking
locked still locked come on out come on
out
hey where did you come from do you have
anything to do with the murder
oh not talking you look guilty
oh yeah
sure who else wants some
Bama framerate just took a nosedive
Erica's ass better I'm about that room
in there hello is this the archives yeah
you're not as bad as the other ones I'm
okay with you
[ __ ] off nope nope aha chair what are
you doing stop dancing and get serious
there's a no there's a secret route
route that leads out of here you can
find the lever down in the study go to
the letter seems to suddenly stop at
this point and the bottom half of the
page is smeared with blood and how did
he write that that's ridiculous
nonsensical is what that is so what's
with this ladder oh hello
turn the box anything up here okay
seems downright cozy hahaha barrier
Kesha
died didn't think so quickly
I need to go down to this study and pull
the lever anything under the stairs lick
lick lick lick see I put it away going
down thinking too much
take lick
who's there oh hello quake tinderbox
anybody I know yeah in the box
who's out there
nobody
I know me
looks like a whole lot of nothing
yep whole lot of nothing
y'all wouldn't be smart to keep
tinderboxes up with all those books I
think that'd be very dumb not that
dinner boxes can spontaneously combust
or anything but I don't even know what
they think these tender boxes are but
sounds like a match with flint and
tinder okay do the study
this seems conspicuously easy
I'm not challenged at all so the lever
for that secret route route is
supposedly to be here somewhere
I should something carefully I don't
have time to read my own thoughts
anybody home
and their body hello nothing once again
nothing whole lot of nothing
how am I gonna get batteries in a
decrepit old castle house there's
nothing in here there ain't [ __ ] so okay
yeah you're the worst kind of mannequins
get out of here okay
nothing nothing nothing
ah there we go chair get out of the way
not finding anything important
not even monsters wonder what the deal
is those noises are coming from nowhere
hello laudanum morphine oh good better
name I don't think it comes in a bottle
like that though and I don't think you'd
bring it down
all right actually that's all the time I
got for this episode nothing scary yet
just some atmosphere setting so anyway
thank you all so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
part bye-bye